Wanna know what Pinhead looks like underneath all
those pins? We've got such sights to show you.
It was only a matter of time until "Hellraiser"
got the reboot treatment. After all, there aren't
many classic horror IPs left that haven't
been reimagined for modern times. Arguably,
"Hellraiser" could benefit from a reboot
as the original franchise went off the
rails long before it had the chance to
realize its full potential. Instead of
making the most of Clive Barker's unique
mythology, the sadistic saga churned out
a series of underwhelming sequels that were
barely connected to the "Hellraiser" lore.
Who would have guessed this would refer
to the feeling of watching the sequels?
"Pain has a face. Allow me to show it to you."
While it remains to be seen if the new
movie will spawn sequels that take the
franchise to new heights, fans can rest
assured knowing Hulu's upcoming slice of
Cenobite-centric chaos has such sights to show
us. The filmmakers certainly aren't interested
in recreating Barker's 1987 original film, as
evidenced by the casting of Jamie Clayton as
the terrifying sadomasochistic demon Pinhead.
The original Hell Priest was brought to life
by Doug Bradley and his performances solidified
both him and the character as bona fide horror
icons. The new take on Pinhead is quite a
departure from Bradley's version, and early
"Hellraiser" trailers suggest that Clayton has
made the role her own in the best way possible.
Jamie Clayton is unrecognizable in the new
"Hellraiser." Boasting black eyes, pale skin,
scarred flesh, and pins sticking out of
her head, she doesn't look human at all.
However, the performer behind the pins
and grotesque demonic makeup is actually
gorgeous in real life. Television aficionados
will know her from shows such as "Sense8,"
which saw her play an LGBTQ hacktivist
and political blogger named Nomi Marks.
Elsewhere, Clayton is known for her performance
as Sasha Booker on "Designated Survivor" and
Tess Van De Berg on "The L Word: Generation Q."
But now that she's had the opportunity to play
a horror icon, Pinhead might be the role
she's most synonymous with moving forward.
In many ways, Jamie Clayton's Pinhead is
a throwback to the original Hell Priest.
In Clive Barker's novella "The Hellbound
Heart," which the original "Hellraiser"
is adapted from, the cenobites are
often described in androgynous terms,
so making this version of Pinhead a
little less masculine makes perfect sense.
However, David Bruckner has also promised
fans that Clayton's Pinhead will be unlike
any previous iteration of the character.
While speaking to Entertainment Weekly,
the "Hellraiser" director confirmed that the new
Pinhead is a complete reimagining and
praised Clayton's performance. He said,
"We knew we wanted Pinhead to be
a woman. Jamie was just the right
person for the role. A person's identity can
be really exciting for a role in many ways,
but I have to emphasize that Jamie
absolutely killed, that's how we got there."
Additionally, Bruckner wasn't interested in
having Clayton copy Doug Bradley's Pinhead
as the English actor has already perfected
that iteration of the character. He added,
"We didn't want to do a Doug Bradley impression,
we just didn't think that's possible to do.
There will be suffering, but you're going to
get a sense of what Pinhead's desires might
be in a way that hits a little different."
Pinhead will be appearing in your nightmares
when "Hellraiser" drops on Hulu next month.